given more than belief nation today's  messages find the right idea over you  Manoj bhargava the only ideas that are  good are those which are simple and can  be done easily because if they can't be  done easily believe me you know the  reason I have gray hairs over time I  found out those which things which look  really easy are really hard and those  things that look hard can't be done so  if if rookies think that our young folks  think ok you know I even do this  impossible thing no it's not gonna  happen you know you'll find the right  idea that's what that's what we're you  should really go so the question today  today is is the simple idea the right  idea leaving the comments below I'll  join the discussion thank you guys so  much for watching have an amazing day  continue to believe and I'll see you  again tomorrow morning for another shot  of interesting